good morning everybody gratitude journal
live stream 17 coming at your super
excited to be here with you happy
tuesday uh why we do this is to be
grateful for the things that we have to
appreciate the friends the people the
things that are in our lives and not
just constantly strive for more and if
you look at people who are happy any
study unhappiness you always see that
gratitude is a big part of it and so
every weekday 9 a.m. eastern we're here
to share three things that we're
grateful for i share through your mind
you guys share yours in the chat if
you're watching a replay leave it down
below three things are you great before
and if you do that consistently you will
be a much happier person and i think
that's important so the to keep the two
key thief not speaking about today the
two key things to keep in mind one its
daily every day rave it's not just once
a week you feel great for that one day
but just like brushing your teeth just
like making it better just like eating
breakfast it's everyday it's part of
your mental hygiene and two you have to
actually stop to feel it you know you
gotta not just lists three things off
but actually take a few seconds to just
sit there and actually feel why you're
grateful for that thing and just asking
yourself why leads to a sentence or two
and that's enough that's what you need
to make sure that you feel the benefits
of it so i'm gonna share three things
that I am grateful for and then I'm
gonna give some shoutouts as people
watching live so share it in the live
chat number one for me I want to say my
my audiobook team yesterday I went and
did my first session of the audiobook in
my I spoke from ten a.m. to five PM
reading and bringing it and spitting
fire and was so much fun I'm paying for
today I've got a cough my throw
his little sore but the team was really
great help me stay on track told me when
I needed to reduce something and I told
them I want this to be I wanted to be
perfect so I'll do as many takes as you
need just let me know interrupt me
whenever and let's do it and they gave
me some really great feedback and advice
and some super appreciative of them we
got normally for a book they try to get
through 80 pages in a day and we got
through 125 so so we did pretty well and
it's the it's the Canadian studio of
Justin Bieber or two so hopefully we'll
make some history as well with the
recording the second thing I'm grateful
for is my bed I came home exhausted I
just gave everything I had from 10 to
five and just wanted to crash and Nina
was that trauma dance salsa and came
back around 10 40 ish something like
that no not that late 10 1030 ish um and
we just I was just staying out just to
spend a little bit of time with her
watched episode of arrow and then
crashed and I was so careful for my bed
to have a bed to sleep in and just conk
out I fell asleep immediately and had a
solid sleep so I'm happy about that um
and the third thing I'm going to go with
my my publisher to for the book it's a
book themed day today they really care
about matching the color so this color
here is not my brand color this is a
like sample book but it's not the actual
one until they sent me this they fedex
this overnight I think you guys can see
that well it's not focusing I have to
pick the color that I want to use they
all kind of look the same from this
angle but I promise you want to look at
them they're not the same so I got it
last night and I need to check with
daylight what it actually looks like to
pick the color that's going to be
actually on the book and so I'm grateful
for
for the publishing team to care enough
to send me different chip samples to
make sure that they get the color right
so those are the free for me I'm
grateful for my audio team grateful for
my bed and get for my my publishing team
I'm gonna get some shadows I want you
guys to share when your group before
today let's see who we got we got Jay
rise first up thankful for expressive
and comfortable clothing expressive and
comfortable clothing I like it for
clients helping our environment for
stores stories as vehicles for change
and growth I love it Jay rises going
meta today I love it millville agree
before Evan pronouncing my name right
yeah well I'm glad you made that extra
attempt to let me know how to do it man
I appreciate that Google from mistakes I
did in my business slightly which made
me prepared for the future I love that
attitude and that approach the only
people see failure mistakes as final
something to regret but if you can be
grateful for them and learn from them
makes a huge difference in your business
where is Rishi I'm sure we she is
somewhere there she is Rishi is here
haha well hello cup of good morning what
do we got what do we got okay bunch of
chatter I love the chatter I had my
usual Google skull the bottom what do
you guys get before arrest a 2103 hi
everyone welcome back Anthony Maya aunt
is in the house and I've never heard
Antony being contracted to aunt I like
it Sarah good morning good morning what
do we got what do we got when we
grateful for Ozzy hello hello Ozzy and
Jackie checking in i love that what are
you grateful for come on guys would have
got Charles I'm so grateful for the
people in my life I love it me too
Christina with a double with a triple I
I like that go Jay raised and Rishi Jay
rises grateful for audio book teens
Rhetta thanks Evan thank you for tuning
in bro what do we got what do we got
[ __ ]
please give us some tips on how to
rediscover yourself hey in three minutes
we're doing a live live stream answering
business questions on twitch while I
play League of Legends so that's that's
a place for business questions do we got
where we got sabrine I'm grateful for my
health my mom and sisters and my job I
love it much grateful for my chicks
connect group I like that chicks kind of
group who I get to chat with today about
my biz and what I do awesome mastermind
Christina I'm grateful for having
supportive co-workers at a job and for
this time here with you it's awesome
well it's great to have you here
Christina to Robert 420 Robert X 4 20 is
grateful for weed all right rose so
grateful for you for you to have an
audio book coming today I'm grateful for
positive pivots after contrasting
situations hashtag believe for sure
thank you yeah i mean the audio book is
all thanks to you guys you guys kept
asking for an audio book audio book
audio book and so i sent that to my
publisher and they said okay we're going
to do it and then also in the pre-sales
you couldn't pre-order an audio book
it's just not done in the industry but
because of all your feedback and
comments coming in that tipped the tides
and so I'm super pumped for two it was a
it was a lot of fun guys I can't lie
there's a lot of fun yesterday doing it
knowing that people are going to be
listening to this it was a ton of fun it
was a ton of fun um Charles I'm grateful
for being able to unlearn learn and
relearn I love it Kelly morning good
morning Kelly grateful for celebrating
two years as a group fitness instructor
today alright happy Anniversary Kelly
will clap that up happy Anniversary
Kelly I love it great for all those i
grateful for all those i see weekly at
these classes for my fun adorable
daughter and loads of water in the am i
love it hey you gotta drink water every
morning a rest day 21 3 i'm grateful
for my sprained ankle he's doing the
body part of the day wears a no zana
we're missing a body part of the day
even though I have to rest for a few
weeks it gives me a lot of time to work
on my music and my abs I love it sherry
grateful for my surgeon who is going to
fix me good luck with the operation
sherry we're thinking about you J reyez
is grateful to connect with chicks too
and reference too much Anthony today
today's gratitude lists one for each
person who views my channel and learn
something new I like it too for positive
people in the world like Rishi this she
gets to love who makes people instantly
smile Wow like in that and three for the
lemon tea I just drank oh I have some
lemon tea too and there's a quote live
to share it's a quote of the day live to
share all right guys 9-10 thank you for
another awesome morning we're gonna head
over to twitch if you want to join in
for a league of legends business QA hope
you guys have an awesome day remember
the field that gratitude during a day to
make you a happier and more successful
entrepreneur continue to believe or
whatever your one where it is and I'll
see you soon